♪
♪ RACH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STILL HAS NO CLEAR ANSWER ON
BLOCKING THE MEDIA FROM THE
BORDER FACILITIES AS THESE
IMAGES FROM CONGRESSMAN HENRY
CUELLAR.
THE NEXT GUEST RESPONSE CYBIL
FOR DEALING WITH THE MEDIA
REQUEST DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AT THE DHS ALEXA
JOINS ME NOW.
WELCOME.
YOU SAY WHERE THERE IS SMOKE
THERE IS FIRE.
YOU THINK THERE IS A COVER-UP.
TELL US ABOUT IT.
WHAT ARE THEY COVERING UP?
>> YEAH.
WELL, WHEN THERE IS A SITUATION
LIKE THIS, USUALLY THE TRUTH
SETS YOU FREE.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE IS THERE
MEDIA GAG ORDER TELLS EVERYONE
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND THE
MEDIA THEMSELVES THAT THE FACT
ON THE GROUND IS LIKELY MUCH
WORSE THAN ANY OF US KNOW.
AND THAT’S THE ONLY REASON THEY
ARE COVERING UP AND THEY WANT
MEDIA NOWHERE NEAR ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES.
RACHEL: WHAT DO YOU SUSPECT THE
CONDITIONS ARE LIKE BASED ON THE
PHOTOS THAT YOU ARE SEEING HERE
THAT YOU BELIEVE THIS IS MUCH
MORE WIDESPREAD?
>> BOTH IN MAGNITUDE BUT HOW
WIDESPREAD IT IS.
SO LIKELY IT’S WORSE.
SO, IF THERE IS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS INVITED TO A FACILITY,
THEY ARE ONLY BEING INVITED TO
THE FACILITY THAT HAS THE BEST
CONDITIONS THAT IS LEAST LIKELY
TO HAVE ANY TYPE OF POLITICAL
RISK.
RIGHT?
SO YOU GOT AN INVITATION FROM
CONGRESS, YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE
THEM TO THE ONE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO -- EVERYONE EVERYTHING
IS GOING TO BE IN ORDER.
IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
MAKE SURE YOU BREAK OUT OF THE
VILLAGE.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
NOT INVITING TO YOU TALK TO TO
GET REAL FIRSTHAND TESTIMONY.
RACHEL: YESTERDAY WILL
INTERVIEWED JULIO AN INDEPENDENT
REPORTER GOING WITH A
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION AND
THEY ALLOWED THE CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION IN AND THEN THEY
CITED COVID AS THE REACH THEY
WENT LET JULIO IN WHO IS A
REPORTER.
WHOHERE IS WHAT MAYORKAS HAD TO
BLAMING COVID ON LACK OF ACCESS.
>> LET’S NOT FORGET THAT WE ARE
IN THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC.
AND WE ARE FOCUSED ON OUR
OPERATIONS, EXECUTING OUR
OPERATIONS IN A CROWDED BORDER
PATROL FACILITY WHERE HUNDREDS
OF VULNERABLE MIGRANT CHILDREN
ARE LOCATED, NUMBER ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO, WE ARE WORKING
ON PROVIDING FOOTAGE SO THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN SEE THE
BORDER PATROL STATIONS.
RACHEL: THAT GOES TO WHAT YOU
JUST SAID THEY ARE WORKING ON
PROVIDING FOOTAGE PROBABLY THE
BEST FOOTAGE THEY FIND.
HOW FAR UP THE CHAIN DO YOU
THINK THIS ORDER TO BLOCK THE
MEDIA COMES FROM?
>> YEAH.
AT A MINIMUM IT COMES FROM
SECRETARY MAYORKAS HIMSELF.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A MATTER
THAT CONGRESS SHOULD INVESTIGATE
AND FIND OUT WHAT INFORMATION HE
HAS THAT HE IS NOT SHARING AND
ALSO EXPLAIN WHY HE IS MAKING
THIS DECISION AND IT CAN EVEN GO
AS HIGH AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
HIMSELF.
STAY BEHIND THE SCENES A LITTLE
CRISIS LIKE THESE GETTING
REGULAR BRIEFINGS ALMOST UP TO
THE MINUTE NUMBERS AND POLICY
ANALYSIS.
AND WE REALLY HAVEN’T BEEN
GETTING MUCH INFORMATION FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND IT JUST TELLS ME THAT
EVERYTHING IS MUCH WORSE THAN
ANY OF US KNOW.
RACHEL: YEAH.
IT CERTAINLY DOESN’T SMELL
RIGHT.
WELL, THERE ARE SENATORS GOING
THIS WEEK.
A LARGE GROUP.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY GET TO THE